[Applause]
all right
let's check it out we had Arrowhead
Stadium in Kansas City Missouri right
for the Kansas City versus Buffalo Bills
yes we got five tailgate challenges guys
the first one to complete the challenge
is we'll take the win and without
further Ado
[Music]
um
take a selfie with the Andy Reid
look-alike the Second Challenge eat
classic KC barbecue without using your
hands number three spider feels Mafia
member jumping through a table Yeah
number four get someone in a Patrick
Mahomes and Josh Allen Jersey to switch
number five the final challenge convince
someone to let you sit in the driver's
seat of a tailgate bus and honk the horn
my strategies we're gonna go with the
easier ones first and we're gonna move
to the harder ones after that taking a
selfie with the Andy Reid look alike I
think that's just gonna be a random
occurrence we'll just get lucky with
that one beat classic Casey barbecue
without using it the barbecue it that
way okay I don't see any barbecue there
great question guys are you guys making
classic Kansas City Barbecue right now
no no okay all right I'm gonna move on
thank you guys if I got some Kansas City
Barbecue Kansas City Barbecue would this
be considered barbecue
no damn it look I don't eat bread meat
but I need I'm gonna just find maybe
some barbecue chicken who has full pork
do you guys have some classic Kansas
City pulled pork you're gonna leave it
on a plate and let me just go to town on
it without any uh hands can we do it all
right let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
appreciate it I got barbecue sauce on my
face Let's get someone into Patrick
Mahomes and Josh Allen Jersey to switch
I don't know if people are gonna do that
at all today
real quick please hey real quick please
please could y'all for this challenge no
no real quick let's put it right back on
for once two seconds two seconds
two seconds
two seconds
so oh I do see an awesome bus there's an
awesome bus a white Chiefs bus right
ahead of us I think it's gonna be
perfect I'm doing a tailgate Challenger
I need somebody to let me sit in the
driver's seat of a tailgate buttons
door don't work oh my God that's perfect
all right come on come on hey excuse me
hey what's going on hey we're doing a
little challenge
and three miles I get in your bus and
just honk the horn oh yeah go ahead
let's not come on
much better horn than that give me a
horn
foreign
[Music]
I need to convince someone to let me sit
in the driver's seat of their bus and
honk the horn can I do it
I'm feeling pretty good about where we
are the hardest part though is the ones
we got done are the ones that don't
require as much
um luck so I do see him at homes in
Allen Jersey maybe we can convince
people here
I know I had some barbecue I'm clean
tailgate challenges that's okay that's
part of the experience
um we need to convince somebody to
Patrick homes Jersey and someone in Josh
Allen Jersey to swap jerseys that's one
of my challenges just just for the
challenge you guys gotta swap no you
would do it would you swap
just for the challenge I just need
somebody to swap I know it's hard that
you got to put on Bill's Jersey just for
the challenge just a challenge let's go
thank you thank you thank you guys
hey my Holmes Jersey is on the Bills fan
we got a Josh Allen Jersey on the cheese
fans let's go Allen and Mahomes
challenge complete two out of the way I
just need three more
spider builds my
member jumping through a tables
out here uh not yet at least
I'm feeling very good the issue is Andy
Reid are we gonna be able to find it I
don't know and then
Bill's tailgate we got to get to a
Bill's tailgate get somebody jumping
through a table
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh can I get some barbecue I get some
barbecue
this right here is the best chicken wing
you've ever had out here oh I gotta do
it without my hand you want me to feed
it to you
baby yo
yep no air as soon as you know
[Music]
let's go out of here with that Buffalo
stuff back it out of here get out of
here
we got three done
what now we gotta get pick us up Andrew
where Andrew so Lou has three we have
three this is gonna come down to the
wire we need to get this fast I got a
quick question for you yeah what is it
brother I'm trying to find some good
bills tailgates where they might have a
table where I could watch somebody jump
through a table do you know where any of
the big
right over here
that's it baby okay let's go thank you I
appreciate it for you man let's go go
bill
let's see
no that's not Andy
[Music]
are you planning on jumping through a
table anytime soon
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that you tell me that Andy Reid
when it's Andy Reed come on man let's go
I've already got four done I just need
one thing left
to get somebody a Bill's Mafia member to
jump through the table I need somebody
to jump off that thing and then after
that I'm Victorious and we go party
we're gonna keep moving through this
bill's tailgate area we just need
somebody to jump into a table I need a
Bill's Mafia member to jump through a
tablet
always happens
I gotta try to find somebody a Bill's
Mafia member to jump through a table
you know where I can get a tablet
would you do it now
guys we found our bills
[Music]
[Music]
come on come on
[Applause]
we found a table we're gonna go Johnny
a table is getting jumped through we got
the Posse everyone's coming with let's
watch it let's get our board challenge
done let's go
[Applause]
let's go my man challenge four is
complete let's go Buffalo
[Applause]
[Music]
this area looks really good I think
we'll find one
I'm not a scientist or anything I'm
sorry what is it it's a beer ball yeah
she's Hall of Famers
[Music]
we look alike and all running around
here not today
good question somebody just jumped
through a table we already got it
have you seen a fake handed read it all
can I find anybody know when they jump
into the table
to the table I think so man went that
way and everything now they're looking
for an Andy Reid look alike who already
did we already got that yeah
I don't know where it's at I don't know
where it's at it was over there yeah
it was great he was face painting yeah
there'll be another one over there where
all the tents are all right we need
another table Yeah we need another table
let's go
[Music]
I absolutely love the outfit Chief's
Jacob is ready let's go
oh yes yes we found the Andy Andy you
look so much can I take a selfie with
you and yes
give him the Hat oh yeah yeah can we get
the cheese out on him 100
all right dude all right and d and d
all right I got all five
Allen and Mahomes
and D and D I think we're taking this
dub let's go I never I never knew it
would be this hard to find somebody to
jump to a table they do it every goddamn
Sunday I can't find someone with a table
that's all I need
this game you got it
I didn't get it
good match what challenge did you not
get nobody wanted to jump to the table
but he's wearing a Bill's hat
what is that who are you guys oh I got
an awesome guy face painted we got the
whole crowd around he jumped off the car
on the table it was sweet we do have a
few more challenges come in in future
weeks on Bleacher Report but you do have
a loser punishment I'm glad I'm not
getting this you're getting some Kansas
City Barbecue [ __ ] right to the face
let me let me take a look here let's see
what we got
I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
all right I hate to do this but we're
going in let's go
is that uh is that uh what is that
smoking hot Anything is Possible